à
trois.
Qu'il apportera? Reportage
terrain.
- Partout au Québec,
la même photo électorale.
Mais ici, c'est d'abord celle
de la candidate locale.
- Alors, comment va Saint-Henri
- C'est la quatrième fois
que Dominique Anglade
se rend à son local électoral
depuis le début de la campagne.
- Oui bonjour, Mme Dufour,
du Parti libéral du Québec.
- L'objectif en cette journée
de vote par anticipation :
mobiliser les électeurs
pour assurer sa réélection.
- Vous pouvez voter d'avance
plutôt que de voter
le jour même de l'élection.- Maé
élue deux fois députée de
Saint-Henri-Sainte-Anne porte
maintenant un nouveau titre :
cheffe du Parti libéral
du Québec.
E ANGLADE, cheffe,
Parti libéral du Québec
- Je suis capable de porter,
puis de comprendre ce qui se
passe sur le terrain ici, puis
le porter à un autre niveau
pour touécois.
Et donc, ça fait une voix
encore plus forte pour
Saint-Henri de Sainte-Anne,
dans les enjeux qu'ils ont.
- Bonjour, c'est Nicolas,
votre candidat de
C'est sûr qu'être candidat
contre la cheffe d'un parti,
il y a une excitation de plus.
- Le candidat caquiste croit, de
son côté, que le nouveau statut
de son adversaire
pourrait lui être profitable.
NICOLAS HUARD-ISABELLE, candidat
CAQ, Saint-Henri-Sainte-Anne
- Ce que les gens me disent,
c'est qu'ils ont eu
des ministres, ils ont eu
des chefs de parti,
puis là, ils veulent un député.n
qui va être là localement.
- Oui, bonjour, je m'appelle
Guillaume, je suis votre
candidat pour Québec solidaire.
Ça va bien?
Ce n'est pas une question d'être
pour ou contre quelqu'un.
C'est une question de quel
parti, démocratiquement,
va représenter le plus
les intérêts de Saint Henri
de Sainte-Anne.
- Pour le candidat solidaire,
la volonté n'est pas de défaire
la cheffe libérale, mais plutôt
d'offrir les solutions
de son parti aux problèmes
de la circonscription.
GUILLAUMIVARD, cand.
QS, Saint-Henri-Sainte-Anne
- La circonscription, elle est
pas celle de personne. Elle est
pas celle de moi, elle est pas
celle de Mme Angla
elle est pas celle de la CAQ.
C'est une circonscription
électorale comme une autre.
- La circonscription de Saint-
Henri-Sainte-Anne existe depuis
1992 et a toujours été libéralee
l'avait emporté par plus
de 4000 voix devant
Québec solidaire.
- Sais-tu pour qui tu vas
voter le 3 octobre?
- Dominique Anglade.
- Si certains espèrent
tendance du vote
se maintienne...
- I've always voted Liberal
and I think Dominique
is a goo
- ... d'autres se disent
prêts pour du changement.
- On pense à Mme Anglade
puis on trouve ça dommage
parce qu'on respec
on aime cette personne.
Mais les idées de Québec
solidaire, c'est les nôtres.
- La CAQ.- Pourquoi la CAQ?
- Parce que c'est les seuls qui
ont fait des choses qui étaient
bonnes pour nous autres.
- J'ai décidé d'appuyer
le Parti québécois.
- J'ai comme eu peur à un moment
donné que le PQ disparaisse.
Puis je trouvais qu'ils avaient
un bon chef.
- La première fois dans la vie
que je vais voter pour
les conservateurs. Ça prend
un peu de changement ici.
On a besoin de brasser la cage.
- Est-ce que vous gardez
le moral quand même?
- Le moral de la députéesortant.
- Moi, je vais gagner
Saint-Henri-Sainte-Anne.
Je suis confiante, là.
- Consciente aussi que c'est
ici que son avenir
politique se jouera lundi.
Ici Mathieu Papillon,
Radio-Canada, Mon